welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's session on
pioneering or understanding of the human
brain we conclude our clinical updates
track and today's session with the
accomplished dr. Helen Bradley Stewart
neurologist or physiologist and movement
disorder specialist dr. Bronte Stuart's
team was the first in the United States
to implant-- a sensing neuro stimulator
from which they could record brain
signals directly and use the patient's
own neural activity to drive the first
closed-loop neuro stimulation studies in
Parkinson's disease this work has led to
the first multicenter international
clinical trial in closed loop brain
stimulation for people with Parkinson's
disease and dr. Brenda Stewart will lead
this
she's the Johnny K ho family professor
in the department of neurology and
neurological sciences at Stanford
University she's also the director of
the Stanford comprehensive movement
disorder Center the co-director of the
Stanford balance Center and the division
chief of movement disorders in the
department of neurology and neurological
sciences for a complete bio on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
dr. Bronte Stewart's talk is entitled
closed loop deep brain stimulation and
Parkinson's disease using patient
specific biomarkers and therapeutic
window my name is dr. rush micro Shannon
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's we would also like to extend
our special thanks to the brain
initiative program directors and in
particular dr. James net for their
efforts in organizing today's session
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting your questions during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen and type your questions in
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions by email
following the presentation the
presentation is educational and
therefore provides free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right corner of your screen
and follow the process to obtain your
credits neck without further ado please
join me in welcoming
after Helen front a direct thank you
very much for that introduction my
disclosure is I serve on a Medtronic
advisory board in this talk I will
discuss our research into relevant
neural and physiological signals that
may be useful for closed-loop deep brain
stimulation for specific Parkinson's
disease motor symptoms and how we have
used a dual threshold control policy
algorithm based on patient specific
therapeutic windows in the first
feasibility studies of closed loop deep
brain stimulation Parkinson's disease
using a fully implanted neurostimulator
deep brain stimulation is a continuous
electrical stimulation of target regions
of the brain usually at high frequency
by a chronically implanted electrodes
currently deep brain stimulation is what
we call open-loop non-responsive and
continues and what does this mean well
open-loop and non responsive means that
the stimulator cannot sense the brain
activity it is modulating it cannot
respond to the patient's state whether
they're asleep or awake whether their
rest are active it cannot respond to
their dominant symptoms such as trauma
or slowness of movement or gait
impairment or freezing a gait and very
importantly it cannot adapt itself to
their current medication or dopamine
levels it's continuous that means it's
on all the time and cannot automatically
change or optimize stimulation
parameters on the location of
stimulation based on patient's State or
symptom and it uses a one-size-fits-all
stimulation parameters so deeper
open-loop deep brain stimulation as you
know has been very helpful but at what
cost
and what do we need to do to improve
this and to develop closed-loop or
responsive or demand deep brain
stimulation of the brain well we need to
know relevant mural and/or behavioral
features of the disease state or symptom
that will be reliable and
to control variables or drivers of a
responsive or demand-based
neurostimulation system this is similar
to the way the heart rate was initially
used for the first demand based cardiac
pacemakers which were designed once they
could sense the heart rhythm to improve
brady kinesia but sorry bradycardia
without causing other arrhythmias we
also need to use an implanted concurrent
sensing and stimulating neurostimulation
system that works in free moving people
doing their normal activities of daily
living and we need to develop optimized
adaptive and automated algorithms which
have customized to the patient that
their activity state and their symptom
and the medication levels this next
slide shows you the active RPC process
Nexus D system developed by Medtronic
which is the past closed loop deep brain
stimulation system using a fully
implanted concurrent sensing and stimuli
and sent and stimulating your stimulator
which we have used for Parkinson's
disease I'm just going to take you
through this slide in the middle at the
top you can see a diagram of an
implanted sensing your simulation or the
AI NS which is implanted under the skin
in the chest local field potentials or
signals from the brain which are over on
the right top panel can be sensed and
downloaded onto the neuro stimulator and
then the top right panel you can see a
schematic of a Medtronic three three
eight nine tetrahydrocannabinol ik
nucleus and we can record from this lead
the recordings they look field
potentials then can be downloaded from
the AI NS onto a tablet and then onto a
PC via a bi-directional Bluetooth
enabled
conduit called Nexus D on the PC we can
program the PC with the classifier
algorithms meaning what is sensed and
the control policy algorithms meaning
what is sent to the eye NS as the
stimulation parameters which is then
sent back to the brain
now we also use behavioral features of
the disease such as the measurement
tremor which you can see over on the
right in the bottom part of the panel
where a patient is wearing a SmartWatch
and you tooth enable SmartWatch and I am
you and this work was done in
collaboration with Jeff Perrin and
Howard Chisholm the University of
Washington who developed a SmartWatch
that then was enabled to work with the
Nexus T system so we can use using this
system we can develop either neural
based or kinematic behavior based closed
loop in brain stimulation and now I'm
going to show you our initial trial of
kinematic closed loop deep brain
stimulation using a measurement of
tremor such as you saw in the previous
slide so we are measuring tremor that
from the the SmartWatch that's faced
that's wrapped around the hand but is
also resting on the leg and the other
side the contralateral side the deep
brain stimulation is on so we don't have
contamination for the tremor from the
other side of the body in the top panel
in a you can see a red line and there's
a statement that says calibration and
then closer to stimulation during the
calibration phase all therapy is off and
we're measuring the intensity of the
resting tremor from this we can develop
our dual threshold algorithm which is
shown in the lower panel by the blue
line and the magenta line going across
that the length of that panel the blue
line represents the upper threshold of
tremor and the control policy algorithm
states that if the tremor goes above the
blue line then the stimulator is
commanded to increase its intensity or
voltage if the tremor is in between the
blue line and the gentle line then the
stimulator stays at the voltage stat and
if the tremor goes below the magenta
line the stimulator decreases its
voltage what you can see from these two
upper panels is the the voltage is
represented by the blue lines and the
tremor intensity on the lower panel is
represented by the black lines as the
tremor increases above the blue line you
could see the voltage increases and the
system responded very nicely to tremor
intensity in the insert shown by the red
Eero you'll see a blown-up time window
of how we increased voltage and how we
wrapped it up and how we ramped it back
down at half the rate that we ramped it
back up to avoid tremor rebound using
this kinematic closed-loop system we
showed that it was efficacious in
meaning it had a statistically
significant improvement in tremor using
less than 50% of the voltage that the
stimulation would have used if it was on
the open loop model and the actually
stimulator was on roughly 51 percent of
the time it would have been on in the
open loop mode so this was quite a
dramatic savings of energy but I think
what one of the most interesting aspects
of this is how everybody's tremor is
slightly different and you can see in
this diagram this is a different patient
who had very intermittent tremor and
when the tremor occurred the voltage
went up but then the tremor went away
and in the end the closed loop system
was only on for eleven percent of the
time that the opening system would have
been on so this is our first example of
patient specific customized closed loop
deep brain stimulation demonstrating
that if you are using this demand based
brain pacemaker for tremor you certainly
can use this without having to be on all
the time for many patients with tremor
so going back to our diagram of our
closed loop system they told you before
we can now use the neural signals
directly recorded from the brain and use
those as the control variable to drive
deep brain stimulation but first we have
to understand what are the relevant
neural control variables for disease
like Parkinson's disease and this has
been known for many many years and is
shown here by a large study that we
performed in the operating room after we
had placed the deep brain stimulation
leads in the subthalamic nucleus and we
showed that in a hundred and twenty nine
out of 130 s hands using a beat
detection algorithm we could detect
elevation in the power in the local
field potential spectrum in the beta
frequency range
what you see here over in panel B as you
can see a schematic again of that
something Lamech nucleus with the deep
brain stimulator we need implanted in
the nucleus what you can see is are
these carbs designated by the the dark
black line the gray line and the dashed
line show the power spectral density
diagram recording from each of the
channel pairs from the Tetra so the
lowest one is actually from the most
ventral power zero to one the dashed
line which showed the greatest power was
recording from one to two and the middle
line was recording from the most dorsal
pair which is two to three and we you
can see that there's a quite a dramatic
elevation in the basic frequency range
of power suggesting the presence of
neuronal oscillations and excessive
synchrony in this beta region and this
is called the beta rhythm and in panel a
you can see time frequency spectra
grounds which basically show the same
thing so is this a would this be a
relevant signal to use for closely
working brain stimulation
well beta the beta rhythm in Parkinson's
disease has been known about in human
subjects and in animal models for over
eighteen to nineteen years and work done
by Peter Brown swoop in Oxford and and
groups in Europe and in Canada where
leaves can be externalized showed early
on that this beta band is attenuated
when patient take patients take
therapeutic doses of medication showing
that there was an inverse relationship
between the beta band power and the
mobility on medication state on
therapeutic state we then showed
similarly that the on therapy that
improves mobility in Parkinson's disease
notably deep brain stimulation also
attenuated this beta band but you can
see on the top panel here is the time
frequency spectrogram and the black bars
represent randomized presentations of
deep brain stimulation different
voltages and in there over the group you
can see in the lower panel but there was
a nice dose distribution attenuation of
beta band power as we increase the
voltage what's interesting
this became significant as we got about
voltages that basically become
therapeutic so now we have an inverse
relationship between a neural control
variable and the therapy notably
medication dose or deep brain
stimulation voltage or current intensity
and can we use this now to control deep
brain stimulation using a neural control
variable and so this slide shows you
that in fact we can and that we have
developed a dual threshold control cause
the algorithm now using beta bad power
instead of tremor intensity and this is
shown over in panel a the blue line
represents the dose distribution I mean
the voltage distribution attenuation of
beta battle power that I showed you the
experimental model in the previous study
and the black lines of beta increase in
beta decrease show you the dual
thresholds now as I told you beta is
inversely related to voltage so the
highest beta will be recorded where the
DBS system is off shown at beta rest on
the y axis then the alpha beta threshold
will be that recorded at a lower voltage
which I'll describe in a minute and the
lower threshold will be in between the
beta power recorded at the lower voltage
and that recorded at the highest voltage
we want to go to for this patient beyond
which they might get side effects so how
do we determine that well I showed you
how we determined that using tremor
intensity and now we determine this
using Rayleigh kinesia
intensity so in power be the upper panel
shows you bit the raw beta Park luxury
ssin the middle panel shows you how
voltage varies as we incrementally steps
or increase the voltage and the lower
panel shows you the angular velocity
traces on the repetitive
flexion-extension movement
demonstrating brady kinesia what you can
see is that as we increase the voltage
the brady kinesia
improves meaning the angular velocity
increases and from this we can determine
what are the third what is the
therapeutic win
this patient the low-voltage being that
at which they get acceptable but not
optimal improvement and the upper
voltage being that beyond which they get
side-effects the last panel of this
figure shows you how basic power buried
over time using the dual threshold
algorithm and how voltage responded
appropriately
what was interesting was that
determining the upper and lower voltage
and therefore the beta thresholds was
different for different people so now
I'm showing you something in a bicycle
distribution similar to what I showed
you in a horizontal distribution in the
previous slide and if you focus on the
time frequency spectrograms in the
middle of this figure you can see that
we increased the voltage from 0 in the
top panel to 100% which was the upper
voltage in the lowest panel in 25
percent increments and on the left side
of your figure you see the corresponding
ESDS of the measured beta man power at
rest which is shown by the black line on
blue is 25 percent red is 50 percent
pink is 75 percent and green is one
percent and more importantly we also
show the change in beta power during
movement which is what the stimulation
will be recording when the patient's
moving around over on the right-hand
panel you can again see the flexion
extension kinematics and you can see
that this patient began to get some
improvement although it wasn't traumatic
and 50 percent of the upper voltage and
so we might choose VL as 50 percent here
or even slightly higher than that and vu
obviously as a hundred percent and
correspondingly over on the PS DS the
beta power the beta threshold upper
threshold will be that red line and the
lower threshold will be in between the
red and the green spectrum but
interestingly in another patient this
might be quite different and this
patient you can see that first of all
they've got better lower voltages
meaning that at 50 percent they were
almost as good as they were at the vu
and similarly the PS DS during movement
showed not much detriment
from the black to the blue meaning 25%
of the voltage but really showing parts
of dramatic attenuation after 50% again
guiding us to determine patient specific
Russians are using their therapeutic
window trying not to go too high in
voltage and not to go too low so the
next slide shows you the results of
paper that was just published of the
first feasibility study of neural
closed-loop subthalamic nucleus to brain
stimulation in Parkinson's disease using
a chronically implanted neurostimulator
division's who'd been on stimulation for
a mean of 22 months almost two years and
we demonstrated that this was safe and
tolerable in both tremor dominant and
agnes rigid patients you can see in
panel a and B the neural closed-loop DBS
improved brady kinesia and tremor brady
kinesia in both the velocity of the
movement and the frequency of movement
and in c and d you can show that in fact
there was cessation of tremor from
almost on for 100% of the time in almost
all subjects and that the tremor level
went recorded when it was present was
very low notably this was done using
less than 57% of the tunnel electrical
energy delivered during open loop to
brain stimulation so I'll finish with
our interest in studies that are
beginning studies and gate impairment
and freezing of gait and this slide
shows you that we have developed several
metrics for gait impairment and freezing
of gait using shown and panel a and C
are stepping in placed a sponger of
force plates where the patient is
literally picking their feet up
alternatingly at their own pace and then
a forward walking are turning in barrier
course which is shown over and B and D
where the patient gets up from a chair
performs two ellipses around these two
barriers and then two figures of eight
through the barriers around these tight
corners meanwhile having these barriers
that are above eye-level causing them to
go through narrow spaces what we have
shown is that the step in case task and
the Tunney and barrier cost shown here
in Sandy and enf respectively reliably
ELISA
Gate impairment of freezing of gait
which however is not very well elicited
when the patient is just doing normal
forward walking in the clinic as is well
known these traces are those are the
angular velocity from and I am you
placed on the lower leg of patients and
you can see the red and the black
indicate each leg and during forward
walking there's nice alternating strides
I wish to not show any impairment but
once they just stepping in place you can
see with the freezer that there is a
time when they don't get that feet off
the post points so they're freezing and
then gate becomes more a rhythmic
similarly during the tongue and barrier
cost the gate in the freezing present
patient tends to break down and they
tend to have periods where they can't
move forward at all the gate becomes
very rhythmic whereas in the non freezer
their gain is fairly normal and they do
the normal slowing as they go around the
corners that is not a freezing event we
showed that most freezing events
occurred when going around these corners
Ottoman era openings in the turning and
barrier cost and this was similar to
what the patients told us when they were
in their home environment so we've got
kinematic or kinetic signals or
behavioral signals of gait what about
neural signals well here you see in this
figure concurrent neural and kinematic
recordings of a patient performing a
hundred seconds or repetitive stepping
in place I'll take your attention to the
lowest panel to start with in panic in a
where you can see the kinetic traces of
a patient performing repetitive stepping
in place this we initially published in
2011 with nan tell us the first onthe
what we do is we normalize the force to
their body weight so you can see on the
y axis we go from zero to a hundred and
a hundred percent of body weight all the
weight is therefore on that one leg and
therefore the other leg should be at
zero percent for normal gait there
should be a nice alternating sinusoids
out of phase with each other so that
when one leg is at 1% the other leg is
zero and that changes as they step what
you
see is that this patient starts off very
well with nice alternating stepping but
then this stepping breaks down and when
the tracers don't reach 100 and zero it
means that the legs aren't you know feet
are not coming off the force plate which
is a very reliable way of detecting and
freezing episode which is shown by the
letters epi above the freezing episodes
using concurrent and synchronized neural
coatings from the subthalamic nucleus
and see what is happening to this beta
rhythm now the second and fourth panel
are the time frequency spectrograms from
the each STM about that what we've done
is we've taken the movement band which
is shown in the panel B as the frequency
band outlined by the dash lines of the
blue PSD which is the one we've recorded
during stepping in face we take that
frequency band and we take them we've
built in the raw signal to that band
we then rectify that signal and square
it to determine how that band behaves
over time what you can see here are the
dynamics of that we call a movement band
over time during this task during the
normal stepping there are these blue
rectangles which shows that there are
fluctuations in the power in this band
that are a fairly short duration and
these have been determined in animal
models fire and burials with group and
now in Parkinson's disease by our
glutton by Peter Browns group as
physiological or normal beta busts what
we would expect to see in the brain
however as you can see as the gate as
the gate is breaking down we are also
seeing increased power and increased
duration of these beta fluctuations of
beta bursts which are thought to be
pathological and related to the
parkinsonian state then this paper was
recently published are showing that beta
band bursts are indeed pathological in
gate two down straight this this is a
three dimensional rectified time
frequency spectrogram during gate and
we've done is we've taken two hearts
fans and we've done the same
rectification the squaring of the signal
so that we can really look in a
three-dimensional fashion and how the
signal is varying over time we also show
the kinetic trace of repetitive stepping
in place are synchronized in time with
the neural recording the upper three
leaseback here is that of a non freezer
who performed the repetitive setting in
place very well and the lower panel is
that of a freezer in which you can see
again the gate start there's stepping in
place starting up well and then breaking
down over time and what were the results
well we found that in that movement band
powerless higher and bus durations were
longer in freezers versus non freezers
during normal gait so not when freezing
but actually during what looked like
normal stepping in place we also showed
that in the free among the freezers
themselves movement band juke bus
durations were longer during the periods
of freezing of gait increases than
compared to during normal gait when we
applied lower frequency sixty watts
which is known to be helpful to some
people in freezing a gait and higher
frequency on 40 watts DBS both improved
the behavior the freezing of gait and
attenuated beta power and shortly the
movement band Buster ations in the
freezers what was very interesting was
that both frequencies of deep brain
stimulation left unchanged the normal
gait and the shorter bus durations in
long freezers
and this was our first glimpse to
suggest that in fact during gait the
effect of deep brain stimulation is
basically to lift off that pathological
Network hook me believing the
physiological network intact so how can
we finally take this to closed-loop
brain stimulation this spinal slide
shows our early trials are closed-loop
deep brain stimulation for gate using
bilateral laterally independent control
variables and control policy algorithms
in this slide we are using the neck
these system in which were basing this
off beta ban power but as we move to the
art the new system which is called the
summit arson process system under a
brain initiative your h3 grant we will
be now able to do this based on the
actual dynamics of the beta ban part
rather than just power panel a you can
see a patient performing repetitive
stepping in place off on therapy and you
can see that the normal step in place
starts breaking down becoming irregular
and finally landing up in periods of
freezing a gate by the feet do not get
off the horse plates under overlook deep
brain stimulation the patient does much
better but you can still see that there
is some air ethnicity and some freezing
episodes recorded during second place
panel see shows closed loop deep brain
stimulation using the mural control
variable and in the top two panels you
can see how the voltage changed in the
two hemispheres and in the lower panel
you can see that the stepping in place
nap was now performed very smoothly and
without freezing episodes giving us a
very hopeful sign that in fact closed
loop deep brain stimulation may be very
useful for gauging families in freezing
again which are currently very quite
difficult to treat finally I'd like to
thank all the current and former members
of my lab with contributors in this work
over the last four to five years on
collaborations at Stanford our
neurosurgeons Scott Delphi engineer
collaborators at the University of
Washington Cameron McIntyre and
especially our engineer collaborators at
Medtronic but most importantly I'd like
to thank the people with Parkinson's
disease who have volunteered many hours
of their time and energy and without
whom none of this research went
impossible and we are very grateful for
the support of this research from the
groups listed below thank you thank you
dr. Brenda Stewart for presenting that
pioneering talk which will have those
who are suffering from
since disease as a reminder our speaker
will follow up with any questions about
our presentation by email this concludes
the pioneering of understanding of the
human brain session and day 1 of
neuroscience 2019 today's presentations
will remain for on-demand viewing
through June 2019
we've got more excellent talks by
outstanding researchers lined up for
tomorrow day two of our neuroscience
2019 conference tomorrow we'll explore
perspectives under psychiatric disorders
and look at the emerging role of the
immune system in brain function and
behavior processes see you tomorrow